estas elecciones en honduras giran en
torno a un cambio de dirección en el
país para salvar la institucionalidad
digámoslo así o por el contrario dejar
honduras a verse de la corrupción y de
la impunidad qué posibilidades hay de
enderezar el camino de este país
centroamericano como lo vio usted
bueno muchas gracias buenas tardes
en realidad la esencia de la disputa
electoral
en honduras para este 28 de noviembre ya
tenemos pocos días
es realmente entre un régimen
autoritario y corrupto que se instaló en
el país desde el golpe de estado del
y una amplia coalición
poco vista en estos últimos años de
américa latina desde una derecha
democrática por lo que he cruzado
acompañado por los diferentes centros
políticos y sectores de izquierda que
buscan
instalar recuperar la democracia y la
decencia nacional me parece que es ese
ese es el debate central es la esencia y
la disputa así que en este momento está
planteada señor díaz que tanta confianza
hay en este proceso en la transparencia
que pueda tener también en las
autoridades electorales de honduras que
tan independientes son y en la
corrupción que ya prácticamente ha
abordado varias instituciones
el gobierno allí en honduras
bueno esa es la gran pregunta
que tiene la mayoría de la ciudadanía
actores incluso internacionales que está
acompañando ampliamente este proceso
porque hay que recordar que venimos de
un fraude electoral las elecciones
pasadas fueron fraudulentas e incluso
reconocidas por la misma visión de
observación de la organización de
estados américanos que en algún momento
incluso llegó a proponer la repetición
de las elecciones pero dado el
reconocimiento por el gobierno
estadounidense del
resultado electoral la verdad dio muchos
pasos hacia atrás
y si el fantasma está
desgraciadamente hay una
institucionalidad electoral bastante
frágil marcada por muchos descensos
señorías también hay mucha expectativa
en torno a la elección de los
integrantes del congreso nacional porque
precisamente este nuevo legislativo
podría aprobar la instauración de una
misión anti corrupción que podría contar
con el respaldo de otros países o de
organismos internacionales será posible
usted cómo ve esto
es posible es una de las esperanzas que
existe de hecho estas elecciones puede
sufrir un carácter histórico y
despiertan a pesar de la difícil
situación del país muchas esperanzas en
esta amplia coalición de fuerzas de
oposición
tener una mayoría
siempre o una mayoría calificada al
congreso es clave para desmontar todo
este régimen autoritario y para poder
avanzar
y reinstalar una visión internacional
contra la corrupción que ya la tuvimos
pero que fue expulsada a principios de